stephen greer
uh claimed that a skeleton discovered in
atacama region of chile
might be an alien
you reached out to him and
took on the task of proving or
disproving that with the rigor of
science the result is a paper titled
whole genome sequencing of atacama
skeleton shows novel mutations linked
with dysplasia
can you tell this full story
the story was as you put it
right there
correct
reached out
got a sample of the body
did the dna sequencing
then worked with a team of uh two other
stanford scientists and
uh roche sequencing group
roche diagnostics and probably a total
team of about 11 or so people
um and as as is standard
in these kinds of things the professors
actually don't do the work the students
do the work and figured out the answer
uh and then we help them put together
the story
uh
and the story was simply that uh it was
human 100
i went into it thinking it was
originally a monkey
of some sort
um
i got kind of excited a few months into
the process thinking well what happens
if it is an alien
right can you describe some of the
characteristics of the skeleton that
make it unique and interesting primarily
it had dysmorphias of the of the brain
um and so the first thing i did actually
when i got pictures of it i took it to a
local expert at stanford
and he was
on the paper
and
he was the world expert in pediatric
bone dysmorphias though he literally
wrote the book
and
on this because that's what you do you
go to an expert when it's outside of
your field of of interest and he said
well i haven't seen this particular
collection of mutations before
uh or this uh this physiology before but
here's what i think it might be
um and he said but based on the size of
the of the
thing and the
bone density
it would appear to be
like six or seven years old
now again that's the
that's the thing where i think the lay
public
doesn't understand or
takes a speculation like that and turns
it into a fact
no one ever said that it was that age we
only said that the bones made it look
like it was that age
but then we went back and looked for
uh
genetic explanations of why things might
look the way they did
and
if you again read the paper it's very
carefully caveated
to say that these mutations might
result in this but what we did find was
an an unexpectedly
number of mutations associated with bone
growth in this individual and it was
just
a bad roll of the dice right you roll
the dice enough times with enough
people born every year and someone will
roll
the wrong dice
all at once so the sad part about it was
individuals in the ufo community who
wanted to think
that there was some sort of conspiracy
around it
right that
somebody had somehow convinced all of my
students
uh to lie
right i mean come on
you know i would lose my i would lose my
job first of all
uh and they would all be
uh you know in trouble forever
yeah but also it's just projecting
malevolence onto people that
doesn't i don't think exist in normal
populace and especially doesn't exist in
the scientific community the kind of
people that go into science i mean this
is what bothers me with the current
distrust of science
is there they might be naive
they might they might not especially
modern science look at the big picture
philosophical ethical questions all that
kind of stuff but ultimately they're
uh people with integrity and it's just a
deep curiosity for the discovery of cool
little things and there's no
um
there's no malevolence uh
broadly speaking in the scientific
community
so i mean there's a bigger story here
which is
you know there's a hunger in the
populace to discover something anomalous
something new
and um you know science has to
be
both open to the anomalous but also
to reject
the anomalous when the data doesn't
support it right
what do you make of that you know
walking that line for you because you're
dealing with ufo encounters you're
dealing with
with the anomalous
well people have said let's go back to
the atacama case that i was debunking it
well debunking is a loaded term sort of
assumes that you were going in
purposefully to
prove something is wrong
i wasn't i was just going in to collect
the data
and um you know i
i showed that this one was human there
was another
skull that somebody had at one point it
was called the star child they called it
the star child skull i said you know i
looked at it i looked at the dna
sequencing that they had done i said
this is human
end of story
um
the people who owned the thing at the
time
disagreed with me and then eventually
another group came in and proved that i
was right
and it's not about debunking it's about
getting the more spectacular and hyped
cases
off the table i mean the reason i got
interested in is because somebody was
hyping it and not because i wanted to
disprove it but because i just wanted to
know
and let's get it off the table because
it's usually the most
extravagant things that are most likely
to be wrong
somewhere
in the rubble will be something
interesting
and so that's what you do you get the
you get the
the dross off the table
and then somewhere
in the data will be something worth
real inquiry
and that
if you inquire deeply enough we'll be
extravagant yes exactly and that's what
actually excites scientists to i mean
you want with the rigor of science to
actually reveal the extravagant
and so look at crispr as probably the
most perfect example of that these weird
sequences in bacterial genomes all
arrayed one after the other with these
strange sequences around them but when
you looked at the sequences they looked
like viruses
and so how did they get there and lo and
behold after you know a lot of effort
and work well a couple of nobel prizes
went out the door
but these strange
things ended up having extraordinarily
extravagant possibilities
you